she's recording now should I just leave
it on sure by the way my my router had
my Wi-Fi router has been crashing these
past few days
so I'm a little worried that that I
might go wrong and during this talk but
hopefully not I really I don't have any
other options so it's okay we just wait
for you to join us again really you have
a very interesting background
by the way I'm very happy for people to
leave their mics on or interrupt me a
lot I feel like it'll be nice to have
some sort of like sense of an audience I
think we would send out reminders at the
exact same time so have what we started
look like five after
looks like Shweta won't be able to join
us dad yeah I think it's very hard to
find a time that's good for
Oh No
so is this kind of content also in one
of marks lectures not not entirely okay
builds off of that or I'm just asking
about some reading that um yeah I mean
it's primarily from a single injury
paper but we'll just touch on stuff
that's sort of all over the place too so
two more minutes
[Music]
[Music]
all right thanks so much for coming so
this talk is about quantum secure
commitments and collapsing hash
functions so I know other slides and
everything but just to be clear this is
part of this quantum for dummies seminar
and this is more of an informal lecture
about prior work and most of it has
nothing to do with the particular
research that I'm involved in so I'm
giving this talk but please don't treat
me as an expert in this subject
and hopefully this can be a little bit
more of a discussion and than me talking
at everyone else okay so the focus of
today is to talk about the right
definitions for commitment schemes in
the quantum setting and sort of looking
at analogous questions for defining
collisions and hash functions of the
quantum setting okay so just to start
I'm gonna put the definition of a non
interactive equipment commitment in the
classical setting so we have Alice and
Bob Alice has some message but M that
she wants to commit to so she samples
some random string R gets their
commitment C sends it over to Bob and
later on when Alice wants to open his
commitment she just sends along her her
message along with some along with her
opening art and Bob just verifies it
this actually equals C okay so
straightforward crypto 101 stuff what we
want from an armed rack equipment is for
today will say sophistical hiding and
computational binding okay so we want
that sees it hist eclis hides a message
of it M and that if alice is efficient
then then she can't adversarially change
your mind after sending her commitment C
okay
so this should be pretty straightforward
and for the rest of today I'm just gonna
focus on this notion of computational
binding so I'm gonna forget about the
hiding entirely you might actually
notice that some of the equipment's
things you talked about don't even have
height
but this can be addressed by working a
bit harder so feel free to stop me if
that's an issue but but for the rest of
today we're gonna focus on binding okay
so so how should we define binding and
for a commitment scheme well in the
classical setting this is pretty
straight forward and we're trying to
capture this notion a provost like
polynomial time sheeting sender can't
change your mind after sending the
commitment see ok so classically we say
well that means that that means that she
really should be stuck at a single
message so she shouldn't be able to open
to two different messages right you
shouldn't be able to find messages m and
M prime that are different as well as
valid openings for them okay so this is
how we define it in the classical
setting and this definition exactly
captures as a notion that she shouldn't
be able to change your mind okay and in
particular any collision resistant hash
function gives you this property okay so
it doesn't actually give you a hiding
scheme but it a a CR HF it immediately
gives you a computationally binding
scheme if you just use the hash function
as the commitment itself so you just
apply the hash function to M concatenate
R so it turns out that this is not true
for quantum attackers in particular if
what you care about is this is intuition
that your quantum attacker shouldn't be
able to change their mind after sending
The Commitments this classical notion
that you can't find two different
openings doesn't actually seem to be the
right definition okay so this is the
definition that we accept is is the the
valid way to capture this intuition and
or does this notion but I claim the
quantum latest this really isn't the
right thing to go for okay so a
particular that there is a result by by
Unruh building on a prior work of - Russ
- Andrew that shows that there exists a
quantum secure collision resistant hash
function this H tilde where a cheating
quantum preacher can open it to any M of
her choice
so when you use as collision resistant
hash function as a commitments Alice can
send a commitment and then after sending
a commitment she can pick any M she
wants and then open is commitment to
that end okay so if you think about it
as a commitment scheme that that that
doesn't have that's that's definitely
not what we want but somehow this is
still quantum secure as a CHF um
question what do you buy a quantum Takeo
cn8 if you like wanna secure CHF I mean
that a quantum attacker can't find
collisions okay so there exists a hash
function where a quantum attacker can't
find any collision so it can't find two
different openings otherwise it would
violate collision resistance but it
still has its property that it can open
a commitment to any M of its choice okay
so this is really highlighting the fact
that this collision resistance notion is
not actually the the right way to define
computational binding in the quantum
setting and and so how do they so this
is for the usual construction of
commitments from small data specific
construction of commitments from CR HF
is insecure okay so I'm not really gonna
get into the details of this in
particular because I don't know them but
I'll at least sort of sketch how this
works and so you can believe that it's
it's it's plausible this could be the
case I should mention that this is
actually relative to a quantum Oracle
and we don't actually have a sort of
standard model version of this result
with this operation okay so here's what
happens what else this adversarial
committer is gonna do is it samples it
has some way of sampling some
commitments string sees this is a
classical commitment along with a
quantum state and it has this property
that after it sends the commitment it
can pick any m at once and then it can
procure the state accordingly according
to whatever end it wants and it's going
to measure the resulting state to get
some R
then when it sends along the the end
that it shows along with that art that
the receiver will accept and indeed it
it will find some ours such that H till
the NMR is actually equal to the see
that it sent okay
and the reason why this isn't ridiculous
this isn't violate the collision
resistance is that the state is actually
used up by this process okay so this
isn't something that allowed that but
that this adversary can do twice so it
can't actually find a collision because
this is a one time process
you're gonna measure this state you're
gonna get your R but then after that
there's there's no way of actually going
back and trying with a different M okay
so this is this is sort of an important
and subtle point here so I want to pause
here into questions so I have a question
so this still means that given a
commitment string a quantum adversary
cannot open it to two different messages
you're just saying that the adversary
can open it to some message to an
arbitrary message of its choice yes but
it can but it still cannot open it two
different ways it is that would I
destroy yes but if you think about what
you want him binding commitment scheme
we really don't care if we can open it
two different ways we care that that
after it sent its you know there was
only one thing that it could have open
to you know this a this new construction
of mark and others in stock this year
doesn't it give a concrete construction
of concrete construction of these you
know commitments or hash functions
without the Oracle so I know you're at
that work but I would be surprised
because it would give it would give
quantum money ah that they do get
quantum money but you know they think
about it one could think about this is
feature right and that's I think was it
I
I see okay yeah I'm not familiar with
the work I should probably talk to mark
more okay any other questions
so yeah chapter I think the Oracle that
they they're still is an Oracle and they
just basically heuristic instantiate it
with obfuscation
okay yeah yeah so so the Oracle in that
in this new example is a is a quantum
Oracle and particularly it needs to do
quantum things and so we don't even have
a candidate office cater for this IC and
marks thing is a classical Oracle so you
can instantiate it got it okay sounds
good all right okay so I'm going to work
towards as motivating and defining the
the the right way to think about
computational binding for quantum number
stories and so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna break up our adversary into
this sort of two-part adversary so the
at the first part of the adversary this
at the top is going to come up with some
command string C and then she's gonna
output some state some some some qubits
representing our states some cubes
representing her messages and some
qubits representing the the openings are
okay and it turns out the business
without loss of generality so because we
know that this this the second attacker
this the second phase of the attacker is
at some point gonna output messages a
message M along with the random string
are it turns out that you can trace back
these registers and say that this comes
without also generality from measuring
corresponding qubits these these capital
m and capital are registers okay so we
know that these capital m capital r
registers have to exist somewhere and
then I give this arbitrary state vector
so so we know that there has to be some
m in our in our somewhere and then
ass just captures everything else at the
everyday I want to write down okay and s
can be arbitrarily entangled with the
M&R but before I go on I want to make
sure that people are comfortable with
the statement that I can frame an
attacker this way and this is without
loss of generality that there's a first
stage attacker that generates a
commitment see along with cubits SMR and
then the second stage attacker takes in
this SMR and operates in this prescribed
way where it's just going to measure the
m in our registers it's gonna get this
these classical and then lower case and
lower case R and it's going to send that
as the message an opening so so far I
haven't defined anything I haven't
worked towards actually defining what
computational binding is I'm just saying
that any attacker and a commitment
scheme is going to look this way any any
quantum attacker I can write down in
this form and and breaking it up into
this first phase and second phase
attacker is going to make it a lot
easier to write a definition down
if you're confused at this point this is
going to be pretty crucial for the rest
of the talk so I'll give this maybe 15
seconds and another clarifying question
about the classical setting I think is
when we look at up statistically hiding
commitments in the classical setting we
actually usually just only care about
the fact that the university should not
be able to open it to waste not about
the adversary not changing their mind
once they're committed because it's
statistically hiding so we don't even
know what they committed to I am
guessing that the reason that we want
stronger properties in the quantum
setting is because we cannot remain and
extract two openings and singly so so
maybe those types of commitments are
useless yeah I don't have an immediate
answer for you ok we can yeah I'll ask
you later it might come up later anyway
vinod are you saying something I think
you might might be on yeah yeah so so
you know if you think about a three
message protocol like a you know one of
these usual 3 message protocols I send a
commitment and then I get a challenge
back if I can open to whatever I want it
you know depending on the challenge
that's not so cool right so it seems
like you need that maybe I'm missing
something that Sheeta so I think in
those 3 message protocols again how do
we formalize that you need this we
rewind and say well we can extract
things not an option here I think that
that's what I was asking maybe I don't
know maybe this is the same thing with
and they're saying the concept of what
the adversary committed to doesn't exist
for these statistically hiring
commitments for example so I don't know
how to formalize what he committed to in
changing but I guess what I'm what I'm
asking is you know this constitutes an
actual attack right for me that's what
you're saying you know if you the
ability to
actually do that do this open to any
value mm-hmm after the fact it does
constitute does it constitute an attack
against you know some protocol you know
I mean there's an efficient way to write
it should write to me now you know it's
not to imagine using a commitment in
this in a setting where you where you're
allowed to open it to whatever you want
and write like a 3-coloring protocol or
something right I come into a graph and
then I get the data and then and then I
ask you know put it to whatever I want
so where does the sound and sound is
completely breaks down right but it can
be useful in a deniable setting or
something the fact that you can do it
were you saying is it as a commitment
that you can actually do this open to
any message it's actually terrible for
three message protocols okay so I think
in the classical setting the two notions
are equivalent the fact that you can do
any message or you can open to two
different yes and and they are not in
the classical setting okay alright so
people are happy with this two-stage
adversary so the way that we're gonna
motivate this definition is to think
about what a perfectly binding
commitment looks like and we're gonna
try to construct or we're gonna give a
definition that says we want to look
computationally indistinguishable from a
perfectly binding commitments okay so
when you're when your usual definition
falls apart this is a good starting
point you say look what is the perfect
thing and how can I be computationally
indistinguishable from this okay so
that's gonna be the goal okay and so
what's the what is I guess one way to
capture the property of a perfectly
binding commitment well it says that if
you give an opening a valid opening mr
for some commitment see then this means
that m had better be unique
there's no qualifier em just has to be
the the unique M such that there is some
R that opens to this seat right if it's
perfectly binding okay so we're just
going to try to capture this definition
so here's how we're gonna think about it
I'm gonna describe a game and this game
is gonna be the two sides of this game
the left and right hand sides at this
game are gonna be perfectly
indistinguishable for a perfectly
binding commitment and then our notion
of computational binding for the quantum
setting is going to be that these two
sides are going to be computationally
indistinguishable okay so these games
will be a little bit complicated but
with me so again we're thinking of these
games as these two sage attackers so
we're concerned with the ability of this
to stage these two stage attackers
distinguishing from picking out what
side they're on okay so in the first
stage right this attacker comes up with
some classical string see and she
outputs for her her cubist the the state
s her message m and opening art and what
we're gonna do is the Challenger is we
are going to compute this we're gonna
compute this one bit this boolean value
V sub C applied to M comma art and this
is just gonna check whether or not the
the commitments
I'm sorry the the message and the
randomness written and those registers
are actually valid okay so in
superposition we are checking if m and r
are valid openings a valid message
opening pair for the commitment c right
because the adversary outputted C this
classical C and that's going to define
this is this V sub C value right it's
gonna define whether or not this is it's
going to define like what we're checking
against right so we're computing this
zero one bit in super position and the
next thing we're gonna do is we're just
going to measure this bit okay so we
care about is seeing whether or not this
actually is valid so we're so if we get
a one in this measurement that means
that this state
is gonna collapse to a superposition
over valid message opening pairs yeah so
if I get have one it's gonna be valid
pairs and then conditioned on this
measurement being one we're gonna do one
further measurement in particular we're
going to measure the the M registers
okay and this here's the thing if it's a
perfectly binding commitment as we just
discussed this measurement does nothing
right so if it's a perfectly binding
commitment then the moment you see that
this that this measurement does this V
sub C measurement has turned to one we
know that that this this M registers is
uniquely defined okay and when things
are uniquely defined they're not
superposition then you can measure them
for free it's not gonna disturb a state
at all okay so on the right hand side
here I'm gonna have the same thing
except I'm going to skip that
measurement this conditional measurement
where if if the verification passes then
I actually measure that M I'm going to
skip it on the right hand side but for a
perfectly binding commitment these two
things are exactly the same okay
so andr definition
computational binding is just that these
two sides should be computationally
indistinguishable so another way to
think about it is the left-hand side is
kind of the the behavior you get from a
perfectly binding commitment particular
on the left-hand side the second stage
adversary is gonna get a state where n
is already measured and therefore unique
right there's there's no leeway and and
the second state is adversary the second
state adversaries choice in them right
because it's measured and on the
right-hand side is what actually happens
the right if the adversary is succeeding
then this is basically the state that
it's going to get okay so the right-hand
side is what's actually going to happen
when we give it the when we give it the
real scheme and the left-hand side is a
perfect behavior and we want to say that
these two things are computationally
indistinguishable right so if these
adversaries can't tell the difference
then they may as well have been working
with a a perfectly binding commitment
schema and that's sort of the intuition
here so formally the
indistinguishability is conditioned on
the verification being so their
application is zero right both games
about presumably they don't abort they
just install we still pass it on it's
just the measurement doesn't happen
right okay
[Music]
any other questions on this this is
maybe the core definition of the talk
maybe the most like technically
complicated thing in this talk
everything after this point is easier so
that on the left hand side the fact that
you know the final state is actually
classical so does that help you to go
back to the original state but for
instance in rewinding if you want to go
back to the original state you can talk
about that a quick clarification on what
we know just asked so we do need
indistinguishability even if the
verification output 0 yeah yeah that's
that's baked into the definition of a
game
okay so yeah this definition is a little
bit to unpack but hopefully it makes
sense they're really like you can go
back and kind of derive this for
yourself by just thinking about how does
a perfectly binding commitment work and
then what does it mean to be
computationally indistinguishable from
this all right
and in Russia oh is that indeed these
collapse binding commitments this so
these these commitments meeting this new
quantum definition of computational
binding are called collapse finding
particular because on one side you you
sort of collapse the superposition over
the MS so these collapse binding
commitments are implied by things called
collapsing hash functions so sort of in
the same way that a collision resistant
hash function gives you your classical
notion of binding a thing called a
collapsing hash function which I haven't
defined yet gives you this notion of a
collapse binding commitment so in
particular if you just use the if you
just use the hash function itself as
sort of the canonical commitment you get
this collapse binding property and if
you want to go ahead and get some
statistical hiding property you can will
use the standard Halevi Macaulay trick
where you commit to some some universal
hash of your message and and and the
binding proper B follows okay so this
collapsing property this is the
collapsing property of a hash function
which I'm about to define is in some
sense the the quantum analog of
collision resistance and and I'll get
into that in a little bit but when you
first define what a collapsing hash
function is so I'm just going to throw
out one more definition at you guys
but this definition is going to be a
little bit easier than the last one all
right so it's like
an adversary trying to distinguish
between two different worlds and so
they're gonna do basically they're gonna
do the same thing in both worlds up
until the end so what the adversary is
going to do is it's going to come it's
going to come up with an arbitrary
superposition over the input space so
capital H is our hash function the X's
are the inputs it can come up with any
solution it wants over inputs the
Challenger is going to evaluate the hash
function in superposition and depending
on what the challenge bit is the
challenger is either going to measure
the X registers so the input or it's
going to measure the output okay and and
then we get us back to the adversary so
I wasn't writing it here but you can
also assume that there is some some
state registers that are or some state
qubits that are being passed from this
first stage the second stage adversary
and I think generally isn't even written
as a two-stage thing it's just a little
bit easier to think of when we just we
just seen the claps binding definition
but generally in the literature this is
the adversary submit something and then
we just send it right back so definitely
some some state is being passed along
between these between these two stage
adversaries okay so the point here is
that a hash function is collapsing if no
adversary can tell whether or not you
measure the input registers or the
output registers for any superposition
of inputs of its choice okay and these
are indeed different measurements right
as long as H is a compressing hash
function measuring the input is going to
be different from measuring the output
alright because if you measure the input
you're going to collapse to a single
state a single copy a tional basis
vector this ax comma H of X and if you
measure the output you measure H of X
then you're gonna collapse so think
about if the adversary is emitted in
uniform through position over all inputs
it can do whatever it wants but let's
just say it did that then if you measure
H of X then this is going to collapse to
all X it's going to collapse to X comma
H of X for all X that hash to that same
value
okay so as long as it's compressing
these these are two different games any
questions on this definition before I go
on
okay so it yeah it turns out that if you
if you construct a hash function satisfy
this property then using the standard
classical techniques for building
commitments from hash functions you get
the right notion of of klopse binding of
those commitments and and that is it
takes a little bit of effort to show
this and in particular you need to show
that that this this indistinguishability
even holds for partial measurements
because for commitments you're only
measuring the M part of the input so if
you think about the canonical hash
function you're not measuring the whole
thing but but it turns out that that if
you just work through some some quantum
this is true so so so for me the
construction is again you first
universal hash your message let you then
you know the other way around maybe you
you you first apply a one-way
permutation or something and then you
universal hash the is that right um yeah
I honestly don't know well stuff my head
it's it's a yeah I think if you sample
some random X you apply universal I
universal hash to it you yeah but yeah
it's the Halevi McCauley construction
and it works as is if you start with a
top same hash function okay
all right so just for the rest of this
talk I'll touch on three things so first
off talk about how collapsing is indeed
a strengthening of collision resistance
so this is more of a just a warm-up or
sanity check and we'll look at how do we
actually build collapse and hash
functions because these aren't very
useful if we can't realize them and at
the very end depending on time if people
have to go I'll sketch applications to
point somebody winding because some
people have hinted ok so let's see that
collapsing actually implies collision
resistance that it's indeed a
strengthening of the classical notion ok
so suppose you have an adversary that is
actually breaking collision resistance
then I want to construct an attacker
that's gonna break the collapsing game
or win the collapsing game ok so your
attacker find some X 0 X 1 such that
there's a collision what you're gonna do
is in the collapsing game you're gonna
you're gonna send the states I which is
going to be the uniform through position
over X 0 X 1 okay so the Challenger is
just going to evaluate agent super
position right it's gonna get this state
and now it's either going to measure the
input register so if it measures the
input register what's the adversary
gonna get well it's either gonna get X 0
or it's gonna get X 1 right or it's
gonna get this this whole state this
uniforms our position over X 0 X 1 okay
and the point is that you can easily
distinguish these right so if you look
at sort of the if you look at the the
space span by X 0 X 1 those in one case
you're gonna get the vector that lies
exactly in the middle or you're gonna
get one of X 0 X 1 so you just do a
measurement that is where the axes are
aligned with with this this X is
numerous to position over X 0 and X 1
and then you're gonna be able to
distinguish
you know you don't distinguish a perfect
probability but you need non-negligible
distinguishing advantage that's good
so like for each bit you do a hundred
measurement and then you know one of
them is different and then you're gonna
catch okay so so indeed collapsing is a
is at least as strong as legend
resistance yes right so why would the
Challenger compute this III think I'm
missing what is this game here the
adversity finds X 0 X 1 and then yeah so
we're starting with an adversary that's
breaking collision resistance right so
we know it can find some X 2 X 1 and we
want to say that we can get an adversary
that breaks the collapsing game okay so
what's the collapsing game the
collapsing game is the adversary can
submit any superposition it wants over
over inputs to the hash function so in
particular the superposition over at
these X 0 and X 1 the corresponding
collision is allowed what the Challenger
in the collapsing game does is it says
okay you gave me that super position all
I'm gonna do is I'm going to evaluate
agent super position and then depending
on my challenge bit I'm either gonna
measure the the hash register or the or
be the output register or the
implementer right so we saw that if
you've entered the the input register
then you're just gonna get either X 0 or
X 1 and otherwise you're gonna get the
uniforms your position and these two are
just just looking at a geometrically
they're distinguishable thank you
okay so now how do you actually
construct collapsing hash functions so
in the first paper this une rue actually
should be 1616 paper that defined this
notion of collapse binding commitments
and collapsing hash functions wasn't
actually able to come up with a standard
model construction of collapse and hash
functions and left that as an open
problem but they did show through quite
a bit of work that that random Oracle's
at least are collapsing okay so there is
like some hope that this is a reasonable
achievable notion okay but then Unruh
followed this up with another paper age'
[ __ ] 2016 that shows that if you have a
lossy function with lossy rate loss you
know straight 1/2 you can use these to
construct a collapsing hash functions
and this construction is not terribly
complicated but a little bit more than I
want to do for this talk so here's
another construction so this is an
observation with all a Knick and mark
that any somewhere statistically binding
hash function I'll define this if you
haven't seen it don't worry any
somewhere such asleep binding hash
function is already a collapsing hash
function so these are actually
introduced about the same time as
collapsing hash functions and it turns
out this notion this is purely classical
definition it actually achieves glossing
okay and this is I guess this is
unpublished and you'll you'll see why
it's kind of obvious one of those
obvious in hindsight things okay
so I'll show this construction just
because this is the easiest construction
of collapsing that I know of
okay so what say somewhere statistically
binding hash function so it's a hash
function where I'm going to think of the
the input is being broken up into a
number of different blocks so just for
simplicity I'm only gonna have two
blocks but general this can be many many
blocks he's
often thought of as as the result of
some sort of Merkel treat builds up over
these blocks or each block as a leaf of
my country but here I'm just going to
think of two blocks and so summer
systole binding hash functions of two
properties so one is the namesake the
summer statistically binding property
that says that well okay you have this
hash function that works in its normal
mode so that that's denoted by this H
and I'm conflating hash keys and
functions hopefully that's not too
confusing but it has a snore mode H but
it also has these statistically binding
modes so we can generate a sadistic way
binding mode of the hash function for
any I we want so I I is indexing the
different blocks in this case we only
have two blocks but in general you can
have it but be binding to any block of
the input okay so if I give out this
this H I then H I applied to X 1 or X 2
is going to be statistically binding to
the ID block ok so what does it mean to
be statistically binding the ice block
it means that the output contains like
statistically fixes the value of a of X
I so just to give you some more
intuition for that in the first
construction of the summerses sleep
binding hash functions reposed by Kobe
jack and wicks the the result of this
hash was actually an F HG encryption of
the ice block okay so as long as your
fhe scheme has has perfect correctness
and this is going to be sit like
perfectly or such asleep binding right
if applying h i to x1 x2 actually gives
me an F HG encryption of X I then the
hash function
statistically contains all the
information about X I right
and the second property we have is this
index five index hiding property which
works really well in tandem with this
summer systole binding property and the
index hiding property says that the the
hash function in its normal mode H the
hash key is going to be computationally
indistinguishable from the statistically
binding hash keys okay so I can switch
the hash key over to be statistically
binding on like the first block or the
second block or none of the blocks and
and the adversary can't tell which block
if any I'm being binding to intuitively
if you look at this if you think about
this fhe construction if the result of
my hash function is an FHA encryption of
the if' block you shouldn't be able to
tell whether or not I'm actually
encrypting something and ripping garbage
or encrypting which block okay so this
is a purely classical definition but it
turns out that any summers of sleep
binding hash functions is collapsing so
here's how you see this well so this is
what we want to show right you want to
show that these two hybrids are
indistinguishable or on top hybrid is
just one mode of the collapsing game and
the bottom hybrid is the other mode so
the top one is the I measure the output
mode of the game and the bottom one is I
measure the input okay so I want to show
that these two are indistinguishable and
I'm going to use the summer such as
sleep binding property to show this so
hopefully this is clear I'm just I'm
writing x1 x2 is that the two different
blocks of the of the hash function but
otherwise this is nothing we haven't
seen before okay so I'm starting in this
first hybrid where we measure this we
measure the output of the hash function
and what we can do in this first step is
well by index hiding we can change the
hash function to be binding on the first
block okay
so that's immediate and now now we've
switched to this h1 so hash functions
binding in the first block and that
means that we can measure x1 for free
all right because we've measured h1 of
x1 concatenate x2 then that means the x1
register is uniquely determined because
this is statistically binding this
contains this met this that we've
measured already fixed x1 right that's
what statistically binding means
ok so that means I can measure the x1
register for free so hi everyone hybrid
2 are perfectly indistinguishable or
statistically indistinguishable because
of the Cystic aligning okay so I can
measure this x1 and because it was fixed
anyway this measurement doesn't do
anything and and that's basically the
whole idea alright so now I just switch
the I can switch h1 back to H and then I
can do this for every single block of
the of the input and and by doing this
for every single block I can then
measure every single block of the input
until I've measured the whole input and
so I just do the exact same steps for
the second block and that I can measure
the input so because somewhere such
asleep binding allows me to bind to
every single block of the input I can
just step through all these hybrids and
then gradually measure all the inputs
until I've measuring the whole thing and
that's exactly what I want out of
collapsing and and these some were
subtly binding hash functions are
implied by any lossy function it's
unclear to me if this this improves in
any way over over the work I think there
is some like loss eNOS found that he
requires and I'm not sure if that goes
away here but I think this is a maybe
conceptually easier way of thinking
about collapsing statistically binding
in Kleist collision resistance right
yeah so in particular the construction
from lab to functions would mean loss in
us right
mr. hawk you know as it needs to be
sufficiently lossy it's uh yeah yeah
then it seems like same assumption but
it's a clearly proof you know yeah sure
sure he right he right so I guess
another question and is there a woof
version of collapse binding you know a
really good question I don't know but I
was wondering this yesterday okay yeah
this is something Justin pointed out to
me and I didn't get a resolution to this
yet any other questions
we're doing pretty good time mister yes
I have a question so actually is the
assumption here that the adversary in
these hybrids he can only measure the
state once and as we prescribe or like I
don't understand why he couldn't measure
like mix up the measurements you know do
some measurement on x2 and so the
aperture you know what I'm saying
measurement I'm saying this is what the
Challenger is doing okay it's the
Challenger yeah yeah sorry I've been a
little bit unclear about who is doing
what but yeah at the beginning that the
Challenger is measuring only the the
output register and then gradually it's
it's it's starting to measure more and
more of the infrared gesture and we're
saying that it each step of the way the
Challenger can get away with doing more
measurements because of the statistical
binding property okay then I guess this
is the only part of the talk that isn't
written down somewhere but these slides
are on my website
okay all right and just to wrap up I'm
gonna sketch some applications to want
some rewinding okay so this is how we
actually use these notions of collapsing
to get some other crypto okay
so I'm just gonna briefly recall the
notion of a sigma protocol and not even
fully recall it just recall enough to be
able to talk talk about what I want to
talk about so well have we'll be looking
at Sigma protocols for simulation art in
a cigarette protocol we have some
Krueger or some verifier they have some
shared input X verifiers trying to learn
whether or not X is in the language
induced by the relation the prover has
an associated witness and they engage in
this three message protocol where the
prover sends a message a the verifier
sends some uniformly random challenge
seat chosen from some challenge space
the prover sends some response back and
just based on the transcript and X the
verifier decides whether or not to
accept or reject okay and these Sigma
Sigma protocols will want to have a
number of properties I'm going to ignore
all of them except for this specialist
on this property okay everything else is
going to be irrelevant to our quantum or
winding discussion okay so special
soundness says that if you have two
valid transcripts so both starting with
the same message a but with two distinct
challenges c1 and c2 if the prover is
actually given the holocron PSA's so if
the verifier accepts on transcript one
which is a c1 z 1 and also accepts on AC
2 z 2 then special soundness says that
whenever you have this you can actually
efficiently extract the witnessed of you
okay and special soundness is
interesting because we'll we what we
actually care about is this proof of
knowledge property which says that if
the prover is succeeding then there
exists some extractor that is actually
able to output
the witness and classically we know that
special soundness implies proof of
knowledge and the idea is that if the
prover is succeeding with some good
probability then it's gonna succeed on
two different seas so we just run it on
one see rewind it remote on the other
sea and then we take advantage of
special soundness to get the witness
okay
so classically we know that special
sound is implies proof of knowledge and
that's just through this for winding
okay and as pointed out earlier this
does not hold for quantum right and the
problem is that measuring z1 is going to
disturb the state of the of the prover
and then once we only measure z1 we
can't actually rewind and return to its
original state and then try again with a
fresh c2z to try with the fresh c2 and
and this is sort of this the central
problem about I think transporting
proofs from the classical crypto world
to the quantum one is that we don't you
sort of have to resolve each is quantum
rewinding difficulties in a number of
different ways depending on your setting
right ideally what you'd want to do is
is somehow make two copies with approver
and then run them both but we know by no
cloning we don't have some efficient
unit area that will take a general
quantum state and make two copies of it
okay so the resolution of this is is I
guess so simple that it's almost
unsatisfying but here it is the idea is
that as long as you have a Sigma
protocol that has some sort of
collapsing property I'm leaving this
kind of unclear because partially
because it's unclear to me and and
partially because it's had a number of
different definitions in literature this
is first this is this was first observed
by or this first constructed by une rue
and then follow-up works that were more
interested in the problem of applying
Fiat a mirror to these protocols and the
quantum random Oracle model kind of
abstracted into his work and and and so
it wasn't quite sure which definition to
go with so I'm just gonna say special
soundness plus some notion of collapsing
is sufficient to get all not a proof of
knowledge but but an argument of
knowledge because this collapsing is a
computational property 3-coloring
protocol for example right instantiated
with statistically hiding commitments
yeah why would you want to do that I
don't know you know not a statistically
hiding commitment rather a collapsing
commitment mmm can you remind an extract
now if it does not fall into this class
I think if you set it up right yeah yeah
but all I'm saying more about this in a
second can I ask a quick follow-up yeah
do you need to transcripts or can you
generalize this to more than to the
special soundness constraint says you
can find up you given these two
transcripts that share the same first
message does that generalize beyond two
because I think that with 3-coloring
you'd need more than two to find the
right colouring are you asking if we can
get away with doing more rewinding x'
yeah yeah right um I think the the
conjecture is that you can get a
with some constant number three windings
okay there there you get you get some
like you get some probability loss of
each rewinding and I think that at least
I've a Glee recall more conjecturing
that it drops off like very quickly okay
okay yeah okay so I'm gonna briefly
explain the main idea behind this and
I'm gonna sleep a lot of things under
the rug so if you catch them I'll be
happy to talk about them but if you
don't I won't okay so the way we'll
think about this is again breaking the
adversary into a two-stage adversary so
this first stage adversary is going to
it's gonna send some message a it's
gonna get the random challenge see and
then we're gonna just pause the
adversary at this point and look at the
the state of the adversary and without
loss of generality the state is some
superposition over these qubits
representing s and z registers whereas
is just arbitrary state of the adversary
and Z is going to be the register that
the adversary and the second stage
measures to produce its response to see
okay and and this this measuring right
so I'm thinking about this adversaries
without all the normality the second
state adversary just doesn't measurement
and then it gets as classical string and
returns this and doing this doing this
measurement is the step that causes
rewinding to fail in general okay
because this measurement disturbs a
stage right how do we rewind the
adversary we're trying to we want to
rewind it and try it again on a
different C so we want to apply some
kind of unitary to undo what the what
the adversary just did but once you do a
measurement that that's not reversible
okay so yeah I guess the the resolution
is so simple once you have collapsing it
almost feels like cheating the point is
that by collapsing I can say that and
this is what I mean by some collapsing
like property it turns out if you design
your your Sigma protocol properly so
that the the first message a is is like
the right the right sort of collapse
binding commitment to something you will
get us in distinguishability but in in
prior works it's been generalized to be
some property of the protocol itself so
this is more or less the property says
that if you know when the adversary
passes these qubits this the state s Z
to the second stage adversary I could
have paused the state in the middle and
just performed a measurement on the Z
and by some by some collapsing property
of the protocol this to say to adversary
can't notice the difference so this
measurement remember is not actually
happening in the real world but we were
saying hypothetically if we were to
introduce a measurement there the
adversary would not be able to detect it
okay so now let's let's let's switch to
the world where we actually have
performed the measurement in the middle
well now once we have in form of
measurements in middle the second stage
adversary who's going to measure that Z
well nothing's gonna happen because Z is
Z has already collapsed to be some fixed
computational basis vector okay so we
introduced this measurement so that now
when the adversary does the actual
measurement nothing's gonna happen okay
so in particular we are computationally
indistinguishable from a world in which
measurement is free
that's what clock King tells us
and so you can get this as I said by
designing the right protocol around a
collapse finding commitments or defining
a collapsing Sigma protocol as I think
it's explicitly done in lose Andrey I'm
not sure if it's probably done in John
Fermo gender than in Chapter two
you can define a protocol a Sigma
protocol itself to be collapsing if it
has sort of has this property but you
can do this the switch drastically
oversimplifying things but but this is
morally what's happening hey can I ask a
quick question yeah so uh you already
showed that random articles are
collapsed binding and then it looks like
these works require some some additional
work to get the pH am i working right so
what was missing Oh probably not the
right person asked i actually know how
these papers work beyond what I googled
yesterday to make this slide you also
need to generate the verifiers challenge
see as the output of the random Oracle
and then prove soundness and I don't
think that that's what I drew should
based on what you just said when we
showed that if you compute a using a
random Oracle then that is collapse
binding is that correct I think so
yeah if anybody is more familiar with
these words feel free to speak up yeah
I'm sure it's something sort of like
that is definitely like a big open
question for a long time for how you
actually apply a Fiat Jameer - I guess
do the standard IID protocol - signature
transformation in the quantum random
Oracle model and and that's what these
works resolved okay so this is basically
what you do to allow the to allow
rewinding because now you can do your
measurement for free or computationally
it's indistinguishable from from a world
in which you can actually do the
measurement so you should just go ahead
and do the measurement in the real world
anyway because the adversary can't tell
the difference okay so I'm lying a
little bit because there there is one
detail that one fairly important detail
omitting which is the fact that you also
want to check that this transcript is
actually accepting and and that is not
something that we can use collapsing to
say that like this particular
measurement checking whether or not a cz
is an accepting transcript this actually
like may disturb the adversary state but
it turns out that that we can handle
this it was actually handled in a prior
work of in rouen or 2012 that shows that
you can handle buying it like random
binary measurements in particular like
you you pick a random measurement that
corresponds to the randomness of the
challenge and you perform a binary
measurement just checking whether or not
the transcript is valid and if you
perform a single binary measurement and
as exceed with if you perform a random
binary measurement and it succeeds with
some probably epsilon then performing
that measurement twice in a row where
protect
perhaps the first measurement disturb
the average average straight state will
still succeed the probability at least
epsilon cubed so prior work of lunar
already showed that we can handle the
fact that we're doing a binary
measurements like that will disturb the
state somewhat but not too much
and that work didn't that work the
originally fall work that showed this
didn't resolve this problem of measuring
Z itself and because that might disturb
the state a lot but once you have the
notion of collapsing you can put these
two together and using this I think in
rew and the 2016 work gets quantum
statistical zero-knowledge arguments of
knowledge for all NP okay sorry i think
there's a chance okay what about so
where did we use the special soundness
property sorry hold on me how do I go
back okay oh it's implicit I guess I
didn't show the second round but I'm
just saying that that this is just the
first round the first round of the
adversary I'm saying that we can we can
actually do this run we can actually do
the measurement and then we can now
rewind and try with a difference see and
the point was that because I'm
collapsing imal actually I'm allowed to
do this in a way that doesn't disturb
the adversary state in a way that I can
notice it does assert the adversary
state but the point is that the
adversary can't tell right so special
soundness like the only issue is that
running this twice and measuring Z like
the first time is potentially issues I'm
zeroing on the first execution and
saying this is actually okay now
that's your question yes yes okay so
yeah it's been in ours let me just
conclude with one open question also I
guess we alluded to this logo before so
we know that any collapsing hash
function is collision resistant but is
the other direction true and so the
immediate answer is well of course not
right we had a separation but this
counter example was relative to a
quantum Oracle and so modulo some recent
work of Mark that I'm not familiar with
we have this interesting question of can
we construct a standard model collision
to some hash function that is not
collapsing okay and it turns out that
this would be really interesting and
this is a marsh paper and that won best
paper at eurocup 2019 if you could
construct such a thing then this
actually implies something called
quantum lightning which you can use to
get a number of really cool applications
like public a quantum money certifiable
randomness which is sort of different
than the notion that I guess recent
works of our Millah and tzvika and
others considered this is this is non
interactive this is not interactive
where I think those are interactive and
this certifiable randomness is publicly
verifiable although you need a quantum
verifier
so this question of I guess separating
CR HS and collapsing is is III think
this this aru 14 and 16 paper we're
looking at this to try to answer this
question of like which definitions are
going to be sufficient to actually give
me a commitment scheme but it turns out
that that showing a separation actually
allows you to build really cool crypto I
[Music]
think I'm done so thanks everyone
[Music]
thanks for me this is a fantastic talk
you likely have feel update you on email
about when we have the next lecture in
the series hey I want to volunteer that
would be great yeah for me yeah can I
ask a quick question
yeah great talk so yeah I never thought
of this random Oracle recording queries
as a collapsing as a version of
collapsing property so that was yeah
that was cool like the I'm sorry what do
you mean by random Oracle recording
freeze and both these fiat Jumeirah
works essentially what they're saying is
you can record the random Oracle query
is without the adversary noticing hmm
yeah and I guess what duck should those
pointing out was that they also require
programming of the random Oracle right
right but if let's say you don't require
programming of random Oracle then can
you just use like a cool apps binding
hash function to instantiate
I'm not sure I guess it collapsing gets
you like one particular property random
Oracle's but I you're asking if it gets
you everything that is not captured by
programming I guess that sounds unlikely
yeah yeah I think the whole recording
quantum crazes is right that that's the
totally orthogonal front from from
collapsing although it's not something
I'm very familiar with yeah thanks yeah
I also have a question about the these
somewhere statistically binding crash
functions sure so you said that you can
have any number of blocks and my
question is like how how many blocks
does it make sense to have I don't know
because it looks like even if you have
one book it would work so so if you have
more books it's easier to get remember
like one block one block is the number
the only number that wouldn't work okay
if you wanted it to be compressing then
you can't have it actually be
suggestively binding to one block
because then it can like then the output
has to be longer the input hmm but then
do you do we know like how because it I
don't know in this in the construction
in the example that you showed you say
that it could be an encryption of X and
then on an encryption of X I this if you
choose the index I yeah any any
polynomial you want I think for any
point on the number of blocks you want
you can you can construct an SSD hash
function that takes in that many blocks
but that's so that doesn't pose a
problem when you to do the hybrid sake
sequence
I don't know isn't there like some kind
of constraint their beds no as long as
you have a polynomial number of blocks
here only and then pick up some pollen
on the loss in these hybrids okay thanks
all right if there's no other questions
I'm going to stop recording at least